- Alright, before we go,
I have one last story from the interwebs,
I promise you're gonna
love, or we hope you do.
This is What I'm Liking.
(bouncy music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
The best couples support each
other through thick and thin,
And this next video proves it.
When an aspiring lawyer took the bar exam,
his wife was prepared to
celebrate either outcome.
She toast his success, if he passed
or attempt to cheer him up, if he failed.
So good for him, he passed.
But in the moment she
hilariously mixed up the two.
So check it out.
- [Tyler] Screw the bar who
wants to be an attorney?
(beep)
(audience laughing)
(Tyler laughing)
- [Christina] Sorry, here.
- [Tyler] Congrats!
(Tyler laughing)
(audience clapping)
You're so lame.
(host laughing)
- Favorite part is, him calling her lame.
(audience cheering and clapping)
We have this couple on the line right now.
Everybody say hi to
Christina and Tyler watching
on Fox 26, Houston at 3:00 PM.
Oh my gosh. First of all,
you might be my favorite couple
ever, but Tyler congrats on,
you know, becoming a lawyer
and the better cookie.
(host laughing)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Thank You.
It was a stressful time
waiting for the results.
But I'm glad that, that's behind this now.
- [Host] Oh my God! Or you thought it was,
and then Christina,
I love that you were
prepared for either outcome.
That was very sweet of you,
but also hilarious that you gave him the
wrong cookie (laughs)
- I mean, first of all,
I just want to say,
I never doubted him, you know,
but I wanted to make sure
I had my bases covered
and we were gonna
celebrate with cookie cake,
no matter what (laughs)
- Love that the next cookie
said never doubted you
after you opened up the
initial cookie that said,
screw the bar, who cares? (laughs)
That was amazing. So Tyler,
you couldn't have done it
without her though, right?
You had a lot of support, right?
- Yeah. I mean,
Christina has been my biggest
supporter since day one.
When I told her that I
wanted to go to law school
in St. Louis, she agreed to up
and move across the country,
away from all of our friends
and family to work full-time
and support me while I was in school.
And,
- [Host] Wow.
- it's a really good thing she did,
because she's the best part of me.
And I have no idea where I would be
or what I would be doing without her.
- Ah, that's so sweet.
That's why she got you,
the big sassy cookie.
She loves you.
Thank you so much, Christina and Tyler
and congrats again, Tyler
- [Christina] Thank You
- I'm liking your post
right now.
- [Tyler] Thank You
And that's not all,
- [Christina] Ah Yes.
- Our season long partner,
Pilot Van Makers of G2,
the go-to pin at the Kelly Clarkson show.
They want to honor ultimate overachievers.
Just like both of you, you're
both funny and awesome.
So they're going to be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars. How's that?
(audience cheering and clapping)
(host laughing)
That's awesome (laughs)
- [Tyler] Thank You
- [Host] Well absolutely,
you can buy so many great American cookies
with that amount of
money, is all I'm saying.